hey david why are the most dangerous
cities run by democrats
so this is a pretty old trope uh and i
maybe we can kind of address this piece
by piece
donald trump and republicans have been
harping on this a lot
uh democrat-run cities are riddled with
violence
so vote for me instead of joe biden even
though of course trump is already
president
and there's still violence in those
cities so here's what there's a few
things you have to understand most
cities are run by democrats period so
violent cities are run by democrats and
non-violent cities are run by democrats
to use crass terminology
additionally the violence is
disproportionately in
urban areas so when you think about
cities instead of areas you start to get
this talking point that trump has been
repeated
so if you look at mayors 35
of the 50 largest cities are run by
democrats
13 are run by republicans and two are
democratic leaning
independents so because more cities are
run by democrats
you have to account for that in your
analysis
the large republican cities are
san antonio i'm sorry san diego run by
republican mayor san diego
jacksonville jacksonville is more
dangerous than the average in florida
it's run by a republican
fort worth texas run by a republican is
a it's more dangerous than the average
of texas in terms of crime rates el paso
texas is safer than average for texas
oklahoma city run by a republican more
dangerous than average
so what you really just have to
understand is that there is a sort of
base rate bias
that you you have to account for the
largest cities run by democrats are the
largest cities in the country
uh crime tends to uh be
greater in places with large population
density for a number of different
reasons that we understand
cities have more crime because they're
more densely populated cities also vote
more for democrats
because they are more cosmopolitan
higher education
rates we know more educated people tend
to vote for democrats instead of
republicans
and that does not directly link to
the crime is because the mayor is a
democrat and this has been
widely debunked and it doesn't even pass
the sniff test there is not
actually any correlation between crime
and democrat democratic mayors
when you account account for crime being
more prevalent
in cities and the fact that democrats
lead
a majority of the cities in the united
states including cities with low crime
rates
now when you look at the south for
example
and the south at both the city and state
level
is disproportionately under republican
rule
they have some of the highest poverty
rates in the united states
does that mean that republican rule
causes poverty
maybe it does and that's a better
argument quite frankly than crime in
so-called democrat cities
but you still have to look at details
and understand more to really know what
it is that is going on
now when this conversation comes up we
also shouldn't
ignore a broader context about crime
that crime has been decreasing for
decades overall
and we might be better served
understanding that
and also looking at areas rather than
just cities what republicans do
is they shift the focus to cities rather
than areas
and that allows them to play on these
bigoted racist ideas that the city is
filled with these scary minorities
who are going to rob you and sexually
assault you and sort of like the willy
horton ad
type of mentality what that
shifts attention away from is the
reality that republican dominated areas
have violent crime that on a per capita
basis
is just as bad as a lot of the cities
cities have more people and have more
population density
so you are going to see more crime in
sort of an absolute sense so when trump
talks about the number of shootings in a
city
those are not per capita numbers and in
order to really
assess this you have to zoom out a
little bit and look at areas
rather than just cities and of course
cities overwhelmingly
run by democrats because democrats tend
to be more interested in being in cities
it really throws the entire idea in the
trash now one one other thought about
this
even if let me see how to say this the
right way
even if on a per capita basis there was
less violent crime
in republican run areas than
democratically run
areas it ignores the fact that people in
the republican areas
suffer in many other ways as well right
economic deprivation is
disproportionately in the united states
in republican run areas now on a
population on a raw numbers basis they
are less populated areas
but on a per capita basis if you look at
economic deprivation
under investment in government ba
terrible resources
bad infrastructure you know all this
stuff you see it on a per capita basis
disproportionately in republican areas
and that's important to bring into the
conversation as well although it's like
who
i'm talking to you guys the people that
just repeat
violent democrat cities aren't willing
to hear this
so there are those are a few thoughts
we've got a great bonus show for you
today get instant access to the bonus
show by becoming a member at
joinedpakman.com
or a patron at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow one of our sponsors
today
is vincero watches and they're giving
you up to 30 percent off
everything in their store when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch if you're looking for an awesome
way to update your look
the perfect way to do it is with an
elegant high quality
wrist watch when there's a company like
vincero
there is no reason to go spending
thousands of dollars on a watch vincero
is an american company
that's made it possible to own an
excellent watch
without breaking the bank all of their
watches are
masterfully built with high-end
materials
but they're all in the range of about
150 to 250 bucks
i just got a watch from their icon
automatic collection
the one i got is in gunmetal and slate
blue
i love the look it's sleek classy it's
clear that a lot of careful
craftsmanship went into the design
it is definitely my new favorite watch
you'll get up to 30 off everything in
their store
when you go to davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video